[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
bismillah alhamdulillah assalamualaikum
greetings of peace thanks for tuning
into the Deen show I'm Eddie your host
and I will bring you up to speed
inshallah God willing on some current
news that caught my attention before we
get into that and my reaction to it hit
the subscribe button the notification
bell so you can get all of our upcoming
videos as soon as they come out and you
don't miss out alright let's get into
this chopper crash where seven were
killed flying from the Bahamas to Fort
Lauderdale just recently and I'll give
you my my reaction my thoughts on it and
I'll discuss why I actually why I'm
discussing this
investigators in the Bahamas are trying
to find out what caused a deadly
helicopter crash that killed all seven
people on board these images show the
grim discovery at sea among the dead
60-year old billionaire coal tycoon
Chris Klein his daughter Cameron and our
close friend Brittany Searson the Royal
Bahamas Police Force says a chopper like
this one took off from Grand Cay a
tourist hotspot in the abacus Islands
heading to Fort Lauderdale early
Thursday morning Klein's brother tells
NBC News the group took off at 2:00 a.m.
and route to a hospital in South Florida
because one of the passengers was sick
Kline who once dated Tiger Woods's
ex-wife Elin Nordegren was well known as
a philanthropist he donated millions to
charity including two Marshall
University the school named their
state-of-the-art Athletic Complex in his
honor the governor of West Virginia
called him a superstar and a wonderful
loving and giving man today would have
been Kline 61st birthday what exactly
caused this crash remains a mystery it
remains a mystery now the reason I
wanted to talk about this topic was
because this is something that really
helps soften my heart the remembrance of
death it helped me to awaken my mind and
myself to the reality that we're all
going to face that reality of death many
people they don't want to talk about it
they diverge from the conversation make
a joke about it but just when you watch
this you see that one what catches your
attention from this is that the person
was a was a billionaire so you're sure
you you think that the person did
everything in their power to make sure
that the gas was right the helicopter
was tuned up that they had the best
mechanic and nobody's expecting that
that plane that helicopter is going to
go down and you had the age ranges from
his
daughter from 22 years old himself was I
believe 61 and the other five people
that were in the plane for a total of
seven and I'm sure nobody in the
helicopter was thinking okay this is our
day we're gonna expire we're going to
depart from this life and nobody knew
that they would be submerged under water
for days until the rescue came and it's
still a mystery on how that helicopter
went down what kind of life do you think
a billionaire is able to have what kind
of luxuries what kind of possessions is
a billionaire think about the able to
have what's it all worth at the end when
even with all that money millions or
billions you cannot still pay someone to
carry your sickness you can't exchange
their help for your health you can't
have somebody extend your life you can't
have someone die for you you can't have
someone bring you back to life
so this news story when I heard it it
really brought me back to the beginning
of my awakening when I start to really
think and ponder about the purpose of
life why are we here where do we come
from where are we going when we die
death was a catalyst that had me really
take off you know the the topic of death
is something that we should really take
serious if you have a major event coming
up and now you're not preparing for that
major event you would think that person
is foolish you've got a fight coming up
maybe it's in the UFC and now your
coaches and your friends are telling you
hey prepare it's coming up the date is
there it's set and now you junk food
you're not training it can be a
basketball game a football game whatever
sport a major test a major exam and
people are warning you people are
telling you hey you got to take this
serious you got one shot to get this
right you can't go back and retake the
exam
and this is the reality of death that we
cannot go back after it comes you can't
not go back and redo it
you got your shot right now to get it
right so this is something that for us
for me when I see this it just brings
that reality home and I think about an
ayah from the Koran and for the not yet
Muslims out there the Quran is the
verbatim word of God Almighty in Arabic
we say Allah and where law is saying the
Almighty the creator saying calluna
syndicate el bote were in Amman to a
phoner would you recommend okay Yama
famine zuzia nerdy woderful alginate
offical fairs
you
well hi Otto dunya Allah metal guru it
brings us back to the reality that God
Almighty Allah is saying that every soul
will taste death every one of us will
have to experience what they experienced
doesn't matter if you're a millionaire a
millionaire if you're a poor man poor
woman off the street it doesn't matter
if you're black or white from Malaysia
from Arabia from Italy from Romania from
the USA if you're Trump if you're Obama
Bush doesn't matter every soul will
taste death and in the verse the ayah
continues saying and then only on the
day of recompense on the day of
judgement will you be paid back your for
what you did in this life that's when
you're going to get paid then you're
going to go ahead and for the good that
you reaped you sold good you'll get good
back you did evil that's going to come
back to you on the day of judgement
doesn't make sense that at the end
you're watching a movie and then you see
the culprit you see the the game the
evil person is able to commit all sorts
of atrocities and crimes the tyrant to
the oppressor and then you're waiting at
the end for justice to prevail does that
make any sense that the most unjust
tyrants of this world the people who
have killed who have raped who have done
all sorts of atrocities that at the end
they would just fall asleep turn to dust
and not be held accountable imagine
watching a movie like that and the
person just got away the plot at the end
didn't bring justice to the story the
storyline was was without catching this
culprit and there was no justice brought
at the end this wouldn't be a good film
would it but more importantly this would
be something that wouldn't go down easy
with you and it will doesn't make sense
that all the things that are people are
doing in this life and getting away with
that they would get away with it in the
Hereafter
now you have this is something that is
ingrained in all of us to believe in a
day of judgment it's just something
natural to believe in that yes the
person who might have done all sorts of
evil in this life at the end day will be
accountable in the next life so this
ayah this verse is talking about that
that's when you're going to be paid back
in full
free that all the good that you did or
the evil that you did the day of
judgment and then from their paradise or
to Hellfire so then the verse goes on
that only the one who is removed far
from the Hellfire and admitted to the
paradise to the Jenna that's the person
who has achieved the objective the
purpose of this life for the life of
this world is the mere enjoyment of
delusions and this is very powerful very
powerful ayah bringing things home that
the objective of this life is to do
everything that we can in this life to
have a good ending to be awake not
asleep so when death finally comes we're
prepared but how many people are truly
prepared how many people are preparing
for the Dede the departure date and this
is what softened my heart to really
think and reflect any intelligent person
you can be a PhD have a master's degree
a professor a doctor and some of the
most be one of the most intellectual
persons but if you don't get this right
how really intelligent are you that you
put all your investment into a stock
that is declining Bay by day that's your
time in this earth you invested
everything here but you forgot about
there because we're here for a short
amount of time
and now you've amassed all the wealth in
this life but now someone else takes
control of that because you can't take
it and it's another beautiful statement
now this time by the last and final
messenger sent to mankind the Prophet
Muhammad peace and blessings be upon him
you see God Almighty sent messengers
throughout time and they didn't come
with different religions or ways of life
they came with the same message Noah
brought it Abraham brought it Moses
brought it Jesus peace be upon him
brought it and the last and final
messenger in that line of messengers out
of God
love he didn't leave us with our
guidance they all call people to turn
their life their heart in obedience and
in love to their Creator and to worship
Him alone not to set up intermediaries
in that worship and this worship means
to love everything that the Creator
loves to obey Him and to stay away from
everything that he's told us to stay
away from so the Prophet Muhammad peace
and blessings be upon him he had
reiterated this point this important
point that telling us that everything in
this life of wealth material things is
gonna be left behind and you give it
beautiful if you can imagine now next
time you're at the funeral procession
think about this hadith this is in
Behati and Muslim where he said there's
three things that follow a human being
to the grave one is their relatives two
is their wealth and three is the deeds
that they live by the deeds that they
did in this life how did you live your
life did you live your life following
your lusts and desires and you forgot
about your Creator the one who created
you who fashioned you who gave you life
will give you death the one who's
blessed you with all these blessings in
life the innumerable you can't even
count them the amount of blessings that
he's had but you've turned a blind eye
every time a sign came to you just like
this one you turned away you didn't heed
the call to Salah to prayer to Hajj to
fasting the blueprint for life you
thought you knew it all so now what do
you do next where do you go when the
Deaf comes will Malakal molt and now
it's time for you to taste death and you
didn't implement this ayah and run far
from the Hellfire by obedience to your
Creator but you ran towards the Jahannam
by the disobedience to Allah so now the
three things that follow you of that
wealth you're at the funeral procession
procession and you can see the family
comes all the things you paid for
they're wearing it the cars the jewelry
and all the other fancy things they're
coming they're coming everything is
coming to the funeral procession and
then all those things you stay they
go away so you stay or you go away they
stay and then what follows you in the
grave is your deeds what you did in this
life and the number one deed is your
faith your Iman what did you believe in
did you worship a human being as a God a
human being that ate slept defecated was
not self-sufficient or you truly worship
the truly self-sufficient creator that
has an air of the same God Almighty
Allah that Jesus worshipped that Abraham
worshipped that Moses worshiped the one
that's all loving and WA dude the all
forgiving the most merciful that he
wants you to rise to your full potential
to give it your best he knows you're
gonna fall short but just do your best
don't turn a blind eye and don't set up
another God next to God it's only one
God and then did you go ahead and follow
that belief up with the actions the DS
now and you got one shot to get it right
it's not Yolo it's not you only live
once no you live twice you live in this
life and how you lived in this life will
determine your next life so in
conclusion this sign here for us that at
anytime deaf can come it can be you can
be a billionaire with all your money and
you could take all like I'm sure this
billionaire did he took all the
precautions most likely he's got his
family in there he wants to make sure
that he gets from Bahamas to Fort
Lauderdale so he's got a checklist but
you just never know at the end when your
time comes to go it's time to go but are
you prepared for the fight because
you're big in fight you could be the
toughest USC fighter you can prepare for
all of the other things of this life for
all of the exams of this life but if
you're not living and passing the
ultimate test of this life because every
day we're being tested whether you like
it or not and you're either
we're either failing the test or passing
the test and a test the one who grades
it on the day of judgment is the one who
created you the almighty not the
almighty dollar that many people worship
No is the one who created you who
fastened you who blessed you who you're
gonna have to return back to so you want
to return back with a purify heart
knowing that you strove your best to
submit and surrender your will to the
will of the creator and that summed up
with one word Islam you did Islam to the
best of your ability and you were a
Muslim because a Muslim is one who
submits his or her will to the crater
that has an earth and that's that same
way of life it's not a new religion a
new way of life it's been there Phin
that since the first man Adam and that
legacy is continued on that way has
continued on to all these prophets and
messengers they all called humanity to
submit their will to the will of the one
God and there's no deity worthy of
worship except the Almighty the one who
created you and fashioned you so
remember this heed the advice
think about it ponder over it and ask
deep down inside if this is your first
time here in a message like this ask
your Creator to make it clear to guide
you and for those who are living this
purpose living the Deen don't forget
don't forget that we will all face that
departure date soon now let it soften
your heart and for those who have
abandoned salat those who have become
more keen to pleasing the people instead
of pleasing Allah let this be a reminder
to us all to remember who comes first in
our life and that's the one who created
us the one who loves us more than our
than our mother's than anyone can love
us is our crater but do you love your
Creator
do you love him if you love him you're
gonna obey Him and the only way you're
truly gonna love your credit is by
knowing him and you have the Quran and
the Sunnah everything there explains
what we have to do for success who our
Creator is what he wants from us and
then from there the love grows and by
implementing the Deen your Iman starts
to grow inshallah we can go ahead and
take from this as a great reminder
continue to tune in here to the Deen
show
subscribe hit that notification bell so
you can get all of the latest upcoming
videos and shows sent to you and you
don't miss out we'll see you next time
you can also support us on patreon we
have a page there leave us your
takeaways in the comments below thank
you assalamualaikum I went to LA he WA
better cut